I tend to do a lot of videos with
simplified examples and round numbers
but let's take let's let's get a little
bit of dose of reality and actually
analyze a real transaction that happened
just to show to you that some of these
CEOs are selling for well below what the
people paid for them or what they were
listed as on the books and even that the
price is actually probably even worth
less than what the person actually paid
so let's let's just analyze this and
then I'll let you make your own
conclusions so this was a press release
this is part of the press release that
Merrill Lynch sent out on July 28th and
and just remember they had just finished
reporting earnings right as of June 30th
they that's when they do a snapshot of
their book so keep that in the back of
your mind right so it says on July 28th
Merrill Lynch agreed to sell 30 point
six billion gross notional amount of US
super senior ABS CDOs to an affiliate of
Lone Star funds so this is important so
the thirty point six billion what is
that that's the number that either
Merrill Lynch originally paid for it or
the what the amount that they originally
valued those CDOs are so thirty point
six billion gross notional notional I
have a notion it's worth this notional
amount of us super senior that sounds
safe super senior ABS that's short for
asset-backed securities CDOs we know a
lot about CDOs now collateralized debt
obligations to an affiliate of Lone Star
funds so this is a Texas private equity
firm I'll do I'll underline them in
green because I I think they know what
they're doing for a purchase price of
six point seven billion dollars so just
just off that first line just very
superficial before we do any other real
analysis notice that at one time there
was an asset though that someone had a
notion was worth thirty point six
billion dollars and now they sell to
this private equity firm for six point
seven billion dollars so what's what's
the recovery on that asset just
superficially and we're gonna do some
we're gonna dig in a little bit and
realize that the cover e's even worse
than that so they paid they were able to
sell for six point seven something that
they originally thought was worth
30.6 so that's 22 cents on the dollar so
this at least what that first sentence
implies that is 22 cents on the dollar
22 cents on the dollar at least relative
to the original amount that though those
assets were booked at at the end of the
second quarter of 2008 notice the end of
the second quarter of 2008 was four
weeks ago relative to this press release
that's June 30th four weeks ago right
not a lot can happen in four weeks at
the end of the second quarter of 2008
these CDOs were carried at 11 point 1
billion dollars so this is interesting
so Merrill Lynch at one point probably
last year had these assets on their
balance sheet for 30 point six billion
dollars at they to realize that they
were stinky assets and they said well we
have to you know just to be somewhat
genuine we have to write down these
assets a little bit but and notice they
don't want to write around too much
because they write them down too much no
one else is going to want to invest in
Merrill Lynch or maybe they'll say
Merrill Lynch's problem might not even
have anything left but at some point
they said you know what what will will
be pseudo honest with the market and
these things that were worth thirty
point six billion we're going to write
them down to 11 point 1 billion so they
must have taken and what if they did
that in one period I don't know how many
periods it took them to realize that
this 30 point six billion dollar asset
was really worth eleven point one but in
those periods they would have had to
take it what is that a twenty nine point
five billion dollar write down right but
as recent and you know they did that to
look I guess pseudo honest that the
asset is worth 11 billion but they
evaluated 11 billion and then four weeks
later they sell it for six point seven
billion so whatever was on their books
on as far as this asset is concerned
whatever was on their books on July 1 or
on June 30th
what are they were getting recovery
relative to that they're getting six
point seven billion for something that
just four weeks ago not a lot can happen
in four weeks
whoops eleven point one and then I can
delete that so they got sixty cents on
the dollar relative to what was on their
books as of
as of June 30th right so it's a 60 cent
recovery relative to what they thought
it was worth only only four weeks ago
and then they say in in connection with
the sale Merrill Lynch has two will
record a write down essentially we you
know now we sold this thing so now we
have to essentially come to terms with
reality and so they recorded a write
down of 4.4 billion pre-tax and what's
four point four that's the difference
between what they thought it was worth
between the 11 point 1 billion and what
it ended up being worth or six point
seven billion now this is this now what
what's interesting here is that's not
the end of the bad news you might think
that's bad enough they were only able to
get 22 cents on the dollar for something
that they originally valued at thirty
point six or what four weeks ago they
only valued at three eleven point 1
billion right and and I don't think they
got a lot more information I think they
just put that 11 point 1 billion down
and on June 30th just because it was
probably a convenient number enough of a
write down to make it look like you're
writing things down but not so much of a
write down to scare people too much but
this is the interesting part I mean this
paragraph talks a little bit about their
exposure and we can get into that but if
I talked about that I could talk for
another 20 minutes but let's get to this
last paragraph that was buried in the
press release and this is really the
crux of things and this I think will
give you a clue of the shell games that
the financial industry tries to play on
people Merrill Lynch will provide
financing to the purchaser for
approximately seventy five percent of
the purchase price so loans to our funds
they're buying it for six point seven
billion but seventy-five percent of that
is a loan from Merrill Lynch so how much
are they lending let's see six point
seven times 0.75 they're lending them
five roughly five billion dollars right
so Merrill Lynch is lending five billion
limits I don't like the color five
billion so Lone Star says these things
are so stinky we're only going to pay
six point seven billion for them and in
fact there's even there even stinkier
than that in order for me to buy them I
don't even want to buy them with my
money
you're going to have to lend me most of
the money to buy that asset
and even this wouldn't be so bad if you
just lent it generally the Lone Star and
if you know one day you know Lone Star
if these assets were nothing you can
still go after the Lone Star's other
assets right if if you could just go
after Lone Star generally maybe this
loan isn't such a crazy thing because
maybe Lone Star has a lot of assets I
don't know but I suspect that there are
fairly large private equity firm and
this is I mean this is just insult to
injury right here you gotta give credit
to those Lone Star guys the recourse on
this loan so that the recourse is
essentially what you can go after if the
person decides that they don't feel like
paying that loan the recourse on this
loan will be limited to the assets of
the purchaser the purchaser will not own
any assets other than those sold
pursuant to this transaction
so essentially what Lone Star did
because Lone Star does own assets other
than other than essentially this this
this asset that is buying right now or
I'm guessing it does and it's a real
private equity firm but they probably
did is they created a corporation that
does not own anything else right so that
if they default nothing's left so they
created a corporation they capitalize
that corporation with whatever 1.7
billion dollars they so essentially Lone
Star puts one point seven billion
dollars in that fund marrow into that
you know the Lone Star funds or whatever
an affiliate the affiliate is probably
the corporation that they created so
this affiliate is created by Lone Star
Lone Star puts in 1.7 billion dollars
into it Merrill Lynch lends this
affiliate five billion dollars and then
this affiliate buys or you know Merrill
Lynch is able to offload this six point
seven billion on to that affiliate and
this is a special-purpose entity if I've
ever heard of one because it's its
purpose is very special essentially for
Merrill Lynch to take something off of
its books and not have to write it down
all the way because think about what
happens let's say that these assets are
worth zero what let's just say that
they're they're completely worthless and
I should add in the previous video I
showed you why that could be the case
what's the loss to Lone Star
well Lone Star
they don't have to pay the five billion
back we just said the purchaser will not
own any assets other than those sold
pursuant to this transaction and that
the recourse is only those assets right
so if they don't pay that loan back
Merrill Lynch all they can do is take
back those worthless assets and then
what's going to happen
well then Lonestar is just going to lose
1.7 billion dollars or even better what
if those assets are only worth one point
seven billion dollars right if let's say
let's let's think about an example let's
say those assets are worth one point
seven billion dollars and Lonestar says
you know what we don't feel like paying
back this five billion dollar loan
what's going to happen Merrill Lynch is
going to just take back those 1.7
billion dollars of assets so what's the
Lone Star's downside 1.7 billion so
essentially what are they paying for it
they're essentially paying 1.7 billion
and they're kind of sharing the upside
in between one point seven and five so
really if you think that they're paying
one point seven or even a little bit
more really I'm what someone start
putting at risk one point seven so one
point seven billion divided by what was
the original notional value of this
asset so they're paying six cents on the
original notional value and what are
they paying relative to what Merrill
Lynch told its shareholders this asset
was worth four weeks before this press
release they're paying fifteen cents on
the dollar relative to that well anyway
this is a real-world example this was
not made up by me and frankly I don't
think I could have made up something
this outlandish but it hopefully gives
you an idea of what is actually going on
in the real world